is the expanse really over
welcome to sidetrek your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
so i have sources that work with mgm and
they have told me some very interesting
news about the expanse and a possibility
for it to return beyond the season six
that we've just had on our tv screens
now i'm going to start off by saying
officially the expanse the tv series is
done
but as i'm sure you know this series is
actually based on a series of books
babylon ashes is the sixth book in the
series and that's basically what this
series has been based on persepolis
rising though book seven is actually set
30 years after the sixth so
show creators have basically said this
is a natural place to end the series
there isn't we're not going to do this
big 30-year jump and so it just made
sense to end it here
but does that mean the expanse is over
that we will never see on our screens
again
well as i say
i have sources at mgm who have been
leaking the information a lot about
stargate mgm and amazon studios are
getting closer and closer these people
are talking twitter so much more and one
of my sources said following a
conversation with some creative people
over amazon he realized that actually a
storyboard for a trilogy of movies has
been produced
they are at very least considering
making the 7th 8th and 9th books
into a trilogy of straight to amazon tv
movies
now
my initial instinct here is that this
probably isn't going to happen
this series has never actually been
profitable it's just never had the
audience it deserved it's never made the
money it deserved
so why would they go on to make three
more movies
well amazon actually saved this tv
series in the first place because jeff
bezos is actually a fan
he actually read the books when he first
came out and loved them he desperately
wanted to see and save this series and
then very lovingly made sure that it
carried on in the style it was allowed
to alcon television that owned the
rights to this and actually produced the
tv series were allowed by amazon to
carry on doing what they were doing
amazon forked up the money bought the
series and never really forced any of
their ideals or any ideas upon the
television series but does jeff bezos
love for this mean that we could
actually get a trilogy of series
considering it's never really been as
popular as it should have been
remembering this is a tv series that in
the third series that they released got
a hundred percent rating on rotten
tomatoes by critics and a 97 score from
fans
the third series and other series have
been very very well received by critics
and the people that do watch it adore
this show
let's be honest when it got cancelled
along back then there was a massive
petition there was a huge fight from the
fans to keep it and get it back on our
screens jeff bezos listened
and forked up the money
could it happen again
well show runner narayan shankar has
already in a couple of interviews in the
insider and and entertainment weekly
hinted that there is more of this show
to come he has said the door is open for
more content but does he mean really
from that just that there's obviously
three more books that could be produced
or is he trying to hint that maybe
something is on the horizon
well as i say
sources at mgm are telling me that at
very least those three stories are
storyboarded now a storyboard is
basically they look a bit like a comic
book but the scenes of a movie or a tv
series are drawn out very crudely but
they're drawn out to get an idea of
where the series or movie will go
it's something they do very early on
when they're trying to decide whether to
green light a show so that they can show
the executives this is what the show
will look like but also they then use it
the director uses it and creative people
use it to try and figure out cost and
all this sort of thing they can figure
out how many different locations they
need they can figure out order because
obviously when they film a movie they
never actually film it in the order it's
like written you know they'll do this
but they could they could film the first
bit of the movie at the right very end
and
vice versa it depends on when actors are
available when production sets are
available and all this sort of thing and
having a storyboard is is very useful
for that you can actually physically
take it apart and put it back together
again and it allows you to see the movie
in a very visual way
so have the storyboards been created
for the executives to get an idea while
they're trying to decide whether they're
going to produce these three movies or
not or is it actually further along than
that and they're designing and creating
the storyboard so they can start
thinking about cost and creative
schedules and all this sort of thing
well
genuinely if they are going to produce
this i think it will be because jeff
bezos has basically said yeah go on
let's do it
how much they spend on it is going to be
the important part here they are not
going to spend hundreds of millions of
pounds produced in these three movies it
is going to be more like a tv sort of
level of um production value i could see
that the basically the budget being
roughly similar to what the season six
budget was and they only produced six
episodes for that series don't forget
but if we get that sort of budget for
each movie we can get something that is
visually spectacular and don't forget
they can continue to use a lot of the
sets and props and things a lot of the
money to produce this series might have
actually already been spent
so you can
use a lot and save money in lots of
different ways by using the props etc
from the series
and we're going to want them to do that
as well because we want them to continue
the look of the show now my source
doesn't know what stage this is at all
he can tell me is that the storyboards
exist he's seen bits of them and he has
actually he is a huge expanse fan and he
has read the books and he says he
recognized a small section of the
storyboard from the book so he knows
that he's going to be closely linked to
that
and but he couldn't tell me more than
that he at the end of the day he doesn't
know and there are rumors going around
about it that actually a movie is about
to be announced but they're no more than
that
however if it is true this would be
something that i would love to see i
would pref would have loved them to
continue doing the series but if that's
not going to happen and all we're going
to get is a trilogy of movies let's be
honest it's not a bad second place
but what do i actually think is going to
happen
i'm sure that these storyboards do exist
my source has been very accurate about
other things that he's told me so i've
got no reason to not believe him
but in all honesty i'd be surprised if
these series of three films got made um
simply because the popularity of the
expanse
has never been what it deserved if they
do get a trilogy of movies um i think
it'll be for the hardcore fans and the
people that love the show will adore
this but similarly to really firefly
when serenity came out it will never be
profitable
they will be lucky if they break even
but that's the interesting part of this
if jeff bezos is the one behind this and
is actually personally very interested
to produce these three movies they're
not going to care if they break even
because the guy in charge wants it and
the guy in charge gets what he wants
even if it is a penis-shaped rocket
so let's see what happens in the next
few months um this not necessarily going
to get greenly to announce anytime soon
like i say storyboarding is very very
early production
so
i'm not expecting to hear anything
really until the summer but we'll see
what happens
so get in the comments tell me what you
think is this a series you want to see
is a trilogy a movie something that
excites you or would you like to see
this produced in maybe another way
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out you
can also join the channel and for a
small fee each month help me create more
content you can also join us on facebook
the link is in the description
so as always guys please stay safe i'll
see you next time
you